Mesdames et messieurs, voici dix choses
qui sont vraiment stupéfiantes.
Imaginez, si vous le voulez bien, d'avoir à traîner tout sur votre dos.
Ça ne serait pas plus facile pour moi si je pouvais rouler jusqu'à la maison ?
Si, et donc, je pense que je vais inventer la roue.
La roue, mesdames et messieurs.
Est-ce que la roue, c'est stupéfiant ? Dites-le avec moi.
Oui, la roue, c'est stupéfiant !
Les Grandes Pyramides furent les plus hautes structures
réalisées par l'Homme dans le monde pendant 4 000 ans.
Pharaon avait fait déplacer par ses esclaves des millions de blocs
jusqu'au site, pour construire une grande pierre tombale.
Les Grandes Pyramides étaient stupéfiantes ?
Oui, les pyramides étaient stupéfiantes. Le Grand Canyon. Allons !
Il est vieux de près de 80 millions d'années.
Le Grand Canyon est-il stupéfiant ?
Oui, le Grand Canyon l'est.
Louis Daguerre inventa la photographie en 1829,
et plus tôt d'aujourd'hui,
lorsque vous avez sorti votre portable
et avez pris une photo de votre stupéfiant sandwich,
- je sais que vous l'avez fait - (Rires) -
n'était-ce pas plus facile que d'exposer l'image
à des plaques en cuivre recouvertes avec de l'argent iodé ?
Je veux dire, allez, la photographie, c'est stupéfiant ? Oui, bien sûr.
Le Débarquement, le 6 Juin1944,
l'invasion des Alliés en Normandie,
la plus grande opération amphibie de l'Histoire.
Le Débarquement était-il stupéfiant ? Oui, c'était stupéfiant.
Avez-vous mangé des aliments aujourd'hui ? Avez-vous mangé ?
Vous pouvez remercier l'abeille, celle-là,
car si les cultures ne sont pas pollinisées,
nous ne pouvons pas cultiver de nourriture,
et nous risquons tous de mourir.
C'est juste ainsi.
Mais ce n'est pas comme une fleur qui peut simplement
se lever et avoir des relations sexuelles avec une autre fleur,
bien que ça serait stupéfiant.
(Rires)
Les abeilles sont stupéfiantes ? Vous plaisantez j'espère ?
Atterrissage sur la Lune ! Allons !
Apollo 11. Vous plaisantez j'espère ?
Soixante-six ans après que les frères Wright
ont décollé de Kitty Hawk, en Caroline du Nord,
Neil Armstrong était à une distance de 386 242 km.
Soit environ d'ici jusqu'à à la lune.
(Rires)
C'est un petit pas pour l'homme,
mais un bond de géant pour le stupéfiant !
Vous avez sacrément raison, ça l'était.
Woodstock, 1969 : le Rolling Stone Magazine
a déclaré que ça a changé l'histoire du rock and roll.
Les billets coûtaient seulement à 24 dollars à l'époque.
Vous ne pouvez même pas acheter un maudit t-shirt à ce prix-là maintenant.
La version de Jimi Hendrix de l'hymne américain
fut la plus emblématique.
Est-ce que Woodstock, c'était stupéfiant ? Oui, ça l'était.
Les requins ! Ils sont en haut de la chaîne alimentaire.
Les requins ont plusieurs rangées de dents qui poussent dans leur mâchoire
et elles avancent comme un tapis roulant.
Certains requins peuvent perdre 30 000 dents dans leur vie.
Est-ce que ce qui est stupéfiant inspire la peur ?
Oh, ouais, les requins sont stupéfiants !
L'Internet est né en 1982,
et il a pris instantanément le monopole de la communication mondiale,
et plus tard ce soir, toutes ces présentations PowerPoint
se retrouveront sur internet,
et même un gars saoul en Sibérie pourra regarder ces foutaises.
L'internet, c'est stupéfiant.
Enfin, certains d'entre vous ne peuvent plus attendre pour se lever
et me dire combien ma présentation était stupéfiante.
Je vais vous faire gagner du temps. Ce n'était pas stupéfiant,
mais c'était vrai.
Et j'espère que c'était amusant,
et de tous les publics que j'ai jamais eus,
vous êtes le plus... récent. Merci et bonne nuit.
(Applaudissements)